最も僕が大切にしている言葉が責任かもしれないと思います。人にされて嫌なことは人にはしない。これ分かりやすい責任の概念だと思うし、青木サ哲の人生警額
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、責任という言葉についてお聞きしたいんですけれども、ま、青木社長が責任という言葉をどんな風に捉えているのか。
ま、例えば責任って聞いて重荷だって思っ
てできれば避けたいって思ってる人も
いらっしゃれば責任って言うと、ま、
大きなこう体を任されたって感じで喜ぶ人
っていうのが、ま、いろんな捉え方する方
がいらっしゃっていて、当然捉え方によっ
て違う結果って手にされていくと思うん
ですけれども、青木社長は責任ていう言葉
をなんかどう捉えてきたのか教えて
いただけますでしょうか?
今
こう訪ねられてね、マッと浮かんだ言葉
ってあのトルーマン大統領のあの大統領質
に掲げてある言葉って若い時に聞いたんだ
よね。それがあらゆる責任はここで止まる
。いい言葉だなと思った。あらゆる責任は
ここで止まる。で、どういうことかと言う
と大統領以上の責任者はいないわけだよね
。全てをせよ。覚悟だ。私は
アチューメントという会社の代表
取り締まり役として全責任を自分は
やっぱり背負ってきた。言い訳は一切なし
で言い訳したことはない。で、そうすると
シンプルにね、約束を守るということに
なるんですよ。で、約束を守
るっていうことは、ま、言うなれば誠実、
ま、責任を果たす、与えられた役割、職務
、自分の与えられたことに対しては
100%
期待に答える、成し遂げる最も僕が大切に
している言葉がもしかしたら責任かもしれ
ないと思います。そういう捉え方でもう1
つあるのが責任とはとこれはリアリティ
セラピーというねウィリアムグラス博士が
提唱したリアリティセラピーというま日本
語では現実療法というこの現実療法を学ん
だ時に責任とは自分の欲求を満たす時に他
の人の欲求住の妨げをしないこととこれは
ものすごく僕は大きな指針になりました。
自分の欲求を満たす時に他の人の欲求重速
の妨げをする。つまり人を踏み台にして
自分の欲求を満たす。これ極端に言うと、
ま、世の中では犯罪なんかは責任の概念
から見たら無責任な行動ってことになるよ
ね。責任の反対無責任ですから。その無
責任な行動というのは倫理的に見てもまた
いろんな視点で見てやっぱり社会をダメに
すると思います。法律を犯したらもう
ブラックだけど法律を犯さないまでも相手
の立場に立って考えたらそれはないよねっ
ていうことあると思うんだよ。例えば
ブラック企業と言われる会社の目的は利益
ですよね。だ、英理市場主義、利益市場
主義。これはやっぱり働く人の欲求住から
考えたら望ましくない状態。もちろんね、
賛否両論あるんですよ。でもこれ全部英理
市場主義なんですよ。利益非市場主義。こ
責任の概念から見たらクレッションだよね
。まあまあ上げてけば霧りがないじゃない
ですか。いじめだとか差別の問題とか全部
自分の欲求を満たす時に弱い立場にある人
たちの欲求住の妨げをしてるわけじゃん。
雇用契約があればやっぱり雇い主の方が力
持ってるからだからも敷いげられるような
状態が起きたりだからやっぱり労働組合の
問題で今度はだも逆に今度は労働組合も
なんかわけのわかんない何対職代行みたい
なのがとかそのすぐ組み合い問題起こす
ようなことで企業から巻き上げようみたい
もうともかくこの世の中っていわゆる原理
原則から外れた
利己的自分中心の意思決定する人たちが
社会を悪くするんですよ。それはやっぱり
責任の概念。これはやっぱり教育の中心に
置かなきゃいけないのは人にされて嫌な
ことは人にはしない。これ分かりやすい
責任の概念だと思うし、一歩それを進める
ならばね、な、何ごでも人々からして
欲しいと望む通りのことを他の人にも積極
的にしてあげなさいと。
これは、ま、黄金率なんだけど、ま、人格やっぱ愛という概念積極的なやっぱり責任の自立した人の生き方じゃないかなという風に思います。
ありがとうございます。
今のこの責任っていう捉え方って青木社長はこう小さい頃からずっとそういう考え方でいらっしゃったんですか?それともこう何かその捉え方をま変えていくまだったりとかっていうことの中で好点的に育組んでいくことができ
まズバり好転的です。僕はこんな人間ではなかったんですよ。いや、本当にお恥ずかしい話。
あの、昔ね、僕の、ま、親友だった、今も
天国に行った武沢君ていう僕の友人に20
代の全般ね、本当に僕が言ってることで
やってることがあまりにも違ったんで、
言われた言葉があって、あおちゃん自分が
言ってることを全部実行できたらお前絶対
成功者なるよ。って言われたのよ。それ
ぐらい僕は言ってることとやってることが
20代の全般食い違ってたということは
意欲先行型でも言ってたってことは考え方
はあったんだと思うだよ。コアにこういう
人間になりたい、こういう生き方をしたい
、こういうことが良いことだと思うことを
本いっぱい読んでたから。その自分の頭の
中で理想が半保先に行ってて、思考と言葉
が先で行動がついていってない。そんな僕
でした。だけど例えば、ま、だから叱られ
たこともあるよね。僕は本当にお世話に
なった今さんという社長に18歳ぐらいの
時言われた言葉サトシね、学歴ないんだ
から約束だけは守れる人間になれ。証の
時計代になれと。お前時間守れない人間に
なったらダめだと。いっつもお前遅れてく
じゃないかと。本と怒られたね。今時間に
対しての幻格でタイムマネージメント
スペシャリストとして、ま、僕はアメリカ
最大の提長会社デイタイマの日本で初めて
のタイムマネジメントスペシャリストとし
ての資格も取ったんだけど、この僕が若か
時間にルーズだったんですよ。とことは
変わったのよ、俺。あとお金にもルーズ
でした。すいません。本当に若い時にだ
から会社1回20代の全般に閉じなきゃ
いけなくなって。でもそこで得たこと
大きいんですよ。つまり意欲と能力は違
うっていうことですよ。お正月キエンスの
竹々さんていう創業者のことちょっと研究
して色々調べてたらあの人2回会社倒産し
てんだよね。だからそれはね失敗じゃない
んですよ。その2回の倒産で身に染みたん
だろうね。そして変わったんだと思うんだ
よ。それが今の営業利益50%を生み出す
期数を生み出したんですよ。だから人って
やっぱり学習する存在なんだよ。だしてき
たんですよ。私も学習してきました。
そして、ま、正直ね、本当に僕がまだまだ
不完全だけど、一応自分なりに言ってる
こととやってることが食い違わなくなった
のは40歳ぐらいじゃない?偉い時間
かかったね。そう思うわ。それぐらいまで
かかってるような気がする。もちろん時間
だとかお金の約束はもう特のに守れるよう
になったけどそれだけじゃなくて自分の中
にある理想の自分例えば怒りの管理とかま
いわゆる人格者と言われるような
立ち振る舞いやとも僕は人に迷惑をかける
存在にはなってない。今はね、自分のこと
を客観的に見て、あ、俺絶対友人になって
もいい友達になれるなとか、それから僕と
付き合って絶対マイナスのことを与える
ことはないと自分で自分を自己評価した時
に思えるような生き方ができるようになっ
ている。でもそれは相当の年月をかけて
自分を作ってきたってことなんですよ。だ
から僕は、ま、本当にある時人生とは人格
完成の旅だという言葉が出てきたけど、
まあ迎え70歳になり、そういう人生を
自分はようやく生きているのかなと。ま、
おかげ様でね、ナポインヒル財団から
アドバイザーリボードの一員に加えられ、
そしてゴールドメダルを授与してくだ。ま
、今はそれを言っても恥ずかしくない少し
ずつレベルになってきて、でも僕は一貫し
て追求してきたことは責任の概念ですよ。
絶対売上を追ってない。クオリティだけ
追ってきました。
ああ、だからそうね、だ、要するに人を
変えることはできないんだけど、誰でも
自分の人生をよりよくすることはできるの
で、自分がよりよく生きていけばみんなが
自分の人生に対して責任を持ってよりよく
生きていったらより良い社会になると。
1人1人が自分の人生に責任を持つ。経営
者1人1人が自分の会社に責任を持つ。
管理者1人1人が自分の仕事に責任を持つ
。働く人たち1人1人が自分の役割与え
られたものに対して責任を持つ。僕はよく
自分に言ってきた言葉でセールスマンの時
に自分に言った言葉はもし自分と同じ
セールスマンばかりだとしたらこの会社は
一体どうなるんだろう。セールス
マネージャーになった時はもし自分と同じ
セールスマネージャーばかりだとしたら
この会社は一体どうなるんだろう?経営者
になってからはもし自分と同じ経営者
ばかりだとしたらこの社会は一体どうなる
んだろう。素晴らしく発展する
良い社会になると言えるような言われる
ようなまた言いきれるようなやっぱり会社
また経営者でありたいと思ってきたよね。
それが責任じゃないかなと。ま、僕は
家庭人としても父として夫としていろんな
責任をやはり果たしてきたし、これからも
経営者としても、ま、なんて言っても親
から見てやっぱり自慢の息子であって
ほしいね。てうちのお袋もよく言ってくれ
てたようだけれども、これからもそういう
人生を追求していきたいなという風に思い
ます。1人1人がそういう理想に向かって
頑張っていったらいい社会になるんじゃ
ないかなと。ちょっとなんか立派なこと偉
そうなこと言ったけどそんな風に私は捉え
ています。ま、是非ね、え、メッセージを
聞いていただいた方はコメント欄にね、ま
、共感したことは何か一言いただきたい
ですね。そして、え、ハイプの方でね、え
、是非また、え、昨日応援ください。
チャンネル登録できる限りね、応援して
いただきたいと思います。よろしくお願い
します。また次回のYouTubeで会い
ましょう。よろしくお願いします。
だから一応今うちの会社は1回ね、ま、
毎月350名を超える経営者が集まって
くれて、ま、この4月から500人集まる
会場に広げて毎月なんで集まってくれた
くれてるかって言うと受行者の質がめちゃ
良くなってるでしょう、今。でもそれは
おそらく33年研究してきた目標達成の
技術、ま、経営者に提供してきた理念経営
、クオリティカンパニーのを作る具体的な
方法がアチュメント自体ができてることを
お分けみたいにしてやってるので、ま、
偽物ではなかったってことだと思うんだよ
ね。うん。ま、そんな風に思うんだけどな
。ありがたいと思います。あとはうちの
受行性の方々に感謝してます。本当に感謝
だよ。受行生の人たちが実行してくれ
なかったらうちの会社の評判は良くなら
ないわけだからみんなが実行してくれて、
ま、このYouTubeだってね、その
受行生のフォローのために始めたわけで、
ま、気がついたら全受行生7万人なのに、
もうはるかに7人を超えるチャンネル登録
者になってるから、まあね、多くの人に
必要されるビジネス系のYouTubeの
ね、番組になったんだろうなと思って、
ありがたいなと思ってます。うん。そんな
感じかな。ま、これからもこの責任を追求
していきたいなと思ってます。